well a former GOP rising star faces new
calls to resign after the release of a
report detailing a woman's accusations
of unwanted sexual encounters a special
Missouri House committee issued the
report about Missouri governor Eric
Greitens yesterday in it the governor's
former hairdresser claimed he may have
coerced her into oral sex and slapped
her Greitens was charged in February
with a felony for allegedly taking and
transmitting a non-consensual photo of
the woman Jim Axelrod is here with the
fallout Jim good morning
well good morning the committee's report
is so graphic there's a sensitive
content warning on the first page
Governor Graydon's admits he had an
affair with his hairdresser before he
took office but denies it was violent
and non consensual and yet just before
the report came out he was already on
the defensive this was a private mistake
that has nothing to do with governing
Missouri governor Eric Greitens said
Wednesday the allegations made against
him in a new report include lies and
falsehoods I want to say again what I've
said from the beginning this is a
political witch-hunt this is not a
witch-hunt and the committee had no
political agenda the 25 page bipartisan
report mostly focuses on testimony from
Greitens former hairdresser who says she
was uncontrollably crying during her
first sexual encounter with him in 2015
in a later meeting she said Greitens
slapped her across the face when she
admitted to sleeping with her estranged
husband I was actually really scared she
testified I am a very proud husband and
father in recordings obtained by CBS
News in January the woman appears to
detail some of this same alleged
encounters
some sort of I don't know what it was
and taped my hands to the ring woman
testified that while blindfolded she saw
a flesh and believes grayton stick a
photo of her
she claims great and said if she told
anyone about him everyone will know what
a little [ __ ] you are he clearly used
his power to manipulate her lawmakers
quickly called on Greitens to resign
he's not backing down a court of law and
a jury of my peers will let every person
in Missouri know the truth and prove my
innocence Quentin's trial for that
alleged photo begins next month he
declined to testify in front of a
committee
Missouri's Republican Attorney General
said he thinks Crichton's alleged
conduct is impeachable and he should
step down
what a story Jim thank you